what I want to do in this video is make
sure that we're good at picking out what
the normal vector to a plane is if we
are given the equation for plane so to
understand that let's just start off
with some plane here let's just start
off so this is a plan drawing part of it
obviously it keeps going in every
direction so let's say that that is our
plane and let's say that this is a
normal vector to the plane so that is
our normal vector of the plane it's
given by a I plus V J plus C K so that
is our normal vector to the plane and
let's say that we have so it's
perpendicular it's perpendicular to
every other vector that's on the plane
and let's say we have some point on the
plane we have some point it's the point
X sub P I'll say P for plane so it's a
point on the plane XP YP ZP if we pick
the origin so let's say that our axes
are here so let me let me draw let me
draw our coordinate axes so let's say
our coordinate axes look like that this
is our z-axis this is let's say that's a
y-axis and let's say that this is our
x-axis let's say this is our x-axis
coming out like this this is our x-axis
you could specify this as a position
vector there is a position vector let me
draw it like this let me draw it like
this then it would be behind the plane
right over there
you have a position vector that position
vector would be X P I plus YP j plus z
PK it specifies this coordinate right
here that sits on the plane let me just
call that something let me call that
position vector I don't know let me call
that let me call that P let me call that
p1 so this is a point on the plane so
it's P it is p1 and it is equal to this
now we could take another point on the
plane let's say let's say we're taking
this is a particular problem plane let's
say we just say any other point on plane
X Y Z but we're saying that XYZ sits on
the plane so let's say we take this
point right over here X Y Z that clearly
same logic can be
testified by another position vector we
can have a position vector that looks
like this
and dotted line it's going under the
plane right over here and this position
vector I don't know let me just call it
let me just call it P instead of that
particular that p1 this would just be X
I plus y J plus ZK now the whole reason
why did this set up is because I want to
find given given some particular point
that I know is on the plane and any
other XY Z that is on the plane I can
find I can construct a vector that is
definitely on the plane and we've done
this before when we try to figure out
what the equations of a plane are a
vector that's definitely on the plane is
going to be the difference of these two
vectors and I'll do that in blue so if
you take the yellow vector minus the
green vector or take this position or
you take you will get the vector that if
you view it that way that connects this
point in that point although you can
shift the vector but you'll get a vector
that definitely lies along the plane
even if you so if you start one of these
points it'll definitely lie along the
plane so the vector will look like this
and it would be lying along our plane so
this vector lies along our plan that
vector is P minus p1 this is the vector
P minus p1 it's this position vector
minus that position vector gives you
this one or another way to view it is
this Green position vector Plus this
blue vector that sits on the plane will
clearly equal this yellow vector right
heads to tails it clearly equals it and
the whole reason why I did that is we
can now take the dot product between
this blue thing and this magenta thing
and we've done it before and they have
to be equal to 0 because this lies on
the plane this is perpendicular to
everything that sits on the plane and
equals 0 and so we will get the equation
for the plane but before I do that let
me make sure we know what the components
of this blue vector are so P minus p1
that's the blue vector you're just going
to subtract each of the components so
it's going to be X minus XP it's going
to be X minus XP I plus y minus y PJ
minus YP j plus Z minus
zp K and we just said this is in the
plane and this is this right the normal
vector is normal to the plane you take
their dot product is going to be equal
to zero so n dot n dot this vector is
going to be equal to zero but it's also
equal to this a times this expression
I'll do it right over here so this these
find some good colors so a times that
which is a X minus a XP plus B times
that so that is plus B Y minus B Y P and
then let me make sure I have enough
colors and then it's going to be plus
that times that so that's plus C Z minus
c zp and all of this is equal to zero
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
rewrite this so we have we have all of
these terms I'm looking for right color
we have all of the X terms ax
remember this is spit this is any X
that's on the plane will satisfy this so
ax B Y and C Z let me leave that on the
right-hand side so we have ax plus B Y
plus C is Z is equal to and what I want
to do is I'm going to subtract each of
these from both sides or in other ways
I'm going to move them all over let me
do it let me not do too many things I'm
going to move them over to the left hand
side so I'm going to add positive axp to
both sides that's the equivalent of
subtracting negative ax P so this is
going to be positive a X P and then
we're going to have positive B Y P Plus
do that same green plus B Y P and then
finally plus C zp + C Z P is going to be
equal to that now the whole reason why I
did this and I've done this in previous
videos where we're trying to find the
formula or trying to find the equation
of a plane is now we said hey if you
have a normal vector and if you're given
a point on the plane where in this case
it's XP YP ZP
we now have a very quick way of figuring
out the equation but I want to go the
other way I want you to be able to if I
were to give you if I were to give you a
if I were to give you a equation for a
plane where I were to say ax plus B y
plus cz is equal to D so this is the
general equation for plane if I were to
give you this I want you to be able to
figure out the normal vector very
quickly so how could you do that
well this ax plus B y plus cz is
completely analogous to this part right
up over here let me rewrite over this
over here so it becomes clear this part
is ax plus B y plus cz is equal to all
of this stuff on the right-hand side I'm
sorry on the left hand side so let me
copy and paste it copy and paste it so I
just I just essentially flipped this
expression but now you see this all of
this this a has to be this a has to be
this a this B has to be this B the C has
to be this thing and then the D is all
of this and this is just going to be a
number this is just going to be a number
assuming that you knew what the normal
vector is what you're a B's and C's are
and you know particularly so this is
what this is what D is so this is how
you can get the equation for a plane now
if I were to give you the equation or
plane what is the normal vector well we
just saw the normal vector this a
corresponds to that a this B corresponds
to that B that C corresponds to that C
the normal vector to this plane we
started off with is it has the
components a B and C so if you're given
if you're given equation for plane here
the normal vector the normal vector to
this plane right over here is going to
be a I plus B j plus plus CK so it's a
very easy thing to do if I were to give
you the equation of a plane let me give
you a particular example if I were to
tell you that I haven't some plane in
three dimensions let's say it's negative
three although it'll work for more
dimensions let's say I have negative 3x
plus square root of 2 square root of 2y
let me put it this way - or let's say
plus 7z
is equal to PI so you have this crazy
it's not crazy it's just a plane in
three dimensions and I say what is a
normal vector to this plane you
literally you literally can just pick
out these coefficients and you say the
normal uh normal vector to this plane is
negative 3i plus a square root of 2 plus
2 square root of 2 J plus 7 K and you
can ignore the D part there and the
reason why you can ignore that is
that'll just shift the plane but it
won't fundamentally change how the plane
is tilted so a normal vector to this
normal vector will also be normal if
this was if this was e or if this was if
this was 100 it would be normal to all
of those planes because all those planes
are just shifted but they all have the
same they have the same inclination so
they would all kind of point in the same
direction and so they're normal vectors
would point in the same direction so
hopefully you found that vaguely useful
will now build on this to find the
distance between any point in three
dimensions and some plane the shortest
distance that we can get to that plane